hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to go with you guys through
yesterday's press action on amc we are
having two consecutive green days uh to
finish the week which is quite positive
to me and there are other signals as
well that give me some information about
what might happen next so let's get into
it
so i am on the forward time frame once
again as always guys we take a step back
just to
admire this price action all right so we
were at less than one year ago all right
and we did one leg second leg third leg
up first leg down we are in this leg
down and there is a leg up coming i
believe so now let's zoom in here a
little bit for those who have watched my
previous video
those are still my signals that are
valid so i want to stress this one i
want to point this one very clearly guys
this bullish divergence all right so
what i can tell you about divergences so
maybe for those who don't really know
what it is all right so you have
different types of divergence very
quickly uh this one is to me the easiest
to use and this is the one we are having
so basically we are in the bullish
situation the market is making lower
highs with the momentum starting to go
up so i want to quickly comment on those
divergences first what i like to do i
like to have at least two of them uh on
different time frames to consider the
signal is valid all right so this is a
method that i invented that i apply to
myself that is working is efficient for
me
but be careful with those divergences
all right that's what i'm saying so here
you can see that on the first time frame
we have it on the daily time frame we
don't have it though
because here the momentum is going lower
as you can see
and on the hourly time frame we have it
here okay so we have it on the hourly
timeframe
then
here
you can see that the momentum
from this low here
at minus 2.5 to this low here is going
higher so it's true on the hourly and
the forwards why uh i am checking those
i'm always checking the hourly the four
hours and the daily what i don't like to
have is too many waves here so here we
have one two three four waves it's
acceptable five six waves is not
acceptable so then if i have too many
waves between the lows i would not
consider this as a valid signal for my
divergence so here i have the divergence
on two different time frames the one
hour and four hours all right and this
is gonna impact the price action for
roughly this time okay so what does it
mean it just means that here bears lost
a battle and they're going to remember
it roughly during this time sorry
here they lost the battle because they
had a breakout okay let me explain very
quickly again what the divergence means
guys here okay we broke out below 31 i
remind you guys all right we broke down
here so the bears wouldn't control but
they didn't manage to bring the momentum
back to a lower low so that they have
the momentum with them so they have the
breakout but they're not able to get the
momentum with them what does it mean it
means they are weak so and they lost the
battle here they got trapped it was a
bear trap so a lot of cells got trapped
here and
the effect is gonna stay in the mind for
roughly
the period between here and here because
the breakout is coming from here i
remind you guys all right this is how i
invented this rule and i applied it to
myself and it's giving me good results
but what i like to do is to trade the
divergence is for me not enough it's
just an indication so what i like to do
is to associate those divergences with
breakouts and i am waiting for the
breakout just here guys so this is the
bear camp like i said in my previous
video that is gonna slide down if we
stay here so what we can see here so
under hourly time frame it's not clean
let me go on the flowers
what we can see here guys
i put back my divergence i connect the
high here the high here we can see that
here we had a reaction a sending
pressure that arrived just after the
earnings and that got us this bearish
engulfing followed by a doji candle okay
you can see it clearly on the daily
uh bearish engulfing followed by so here
the scandal completely eats the previous
one that is the small green one gets
eaten by the big red one and then bell
trap again many bears were trapped here
so belcher boot trap bear trap is very
complicated but on the larger scale
the signals are quite clean rejected on
the resistance level and now we are
totally invading the bears camp which is
good all right so this is the orange
rectangle here we are just in it you can
see that we had here a reaction
yesterday so friday exactly on this
trend line okay once again here we tried
to break out it was too early why too
early because we were coming back from
too far all right so we arrived there
already like tired all right after 25
move we were tired all right the bulls
were didn't have enough ammunition here
to destroy this bear camp so what did we
do we got back to take some fresh
ammunition guys and we are just coming
back to the battlefield again that is
here so here there is a fight for now
it's looking quite good to me i like to
see those consolidations just below the
breakout area all right because the
market is gathering strength and
the bells that you know just sitting at
the level but
you know you can see they're not
attacking who is attacking the bulls the
bulls are
trying to go through this resistance so
this is what we want to see if we have
this plus the breakouts plus the
divergence that is already helping as
you can see this would look good to me
so this is what we're waiting for and
once again i need to remind you guys
that as long as we are below this on a
larger time frame
bears are still in control since june so
it's been two three months alright so
this is what we want to see very quickly
let me show you some cool options
strategy once again guys i'm sharing
this on my discord for all of you guys
that are interested just
click on the link in the description of
this video it's still 25 off until
tomorrow then i will have no choice but
making the prices higher because i don't
want too many people there so last
chance for you guys if you want to join
this place and i'm sharing with you this
kind of strategy so to me this is the
best option strategy you can make for
the past two months all right i'm
advising to make this strategy since i'm
back from creation
which is like one month and a half so i
wouldn't have lost money and i wouldn't
have made money either because i'm lo i
lose money below 24 i make money about
40 we are stuck here but the good thing
is that if there was a strong move up by
having this strategy you would be in
alright so this is the important thing
now we can see that at 34 it's a bit
more expensive so once again let me
remind you the strategy
that i really like guys okay so you sell
a put white 24 put because this is the
boot camp so we are not scared to sell a
strike below which we know we won't be
going because you start losing money
below 24 i mean we won't be going at
least until the 17th of september after
that of course if we go there we tested
you know everything can happen i'm just
saying that for now this is very safe to
me then buying for this strike called
why 40 because it was the resistance
level now it's more like 35 but the 35
strike would be more expensive so i
would still stay on the 100 and you can
see that this costs you 360 us dollars
and you can make it even cheaper by
selling sacrificing website performance
above 100 all right so you sell the 100
code you get back 170 us dollars so it
costs you a total of 200 us dollars all
right so this is the cost of the
strategy today and when i showed the
strategy for the first time it was
almost for free all right because amc
was around 31
you know 32
something like this so this strategy was
costing 50 years down if you take it now
it's a bit more expensive but it's still
to me a good play and if you want to
have it cheaper you just go to the
higher strike right you can go to the 50
strike
and now it's free okay
so it depends on what you want to do but
the next resistance level is 46 let me
show you guys this so i start to check
what happens if we break out probably a
strong move especially if we consolidate
longer i i give it here maybe one or
more two days so i don't want to give
some day analysis because it was very
tough so i'm sticking to the longer
timeframe analysis but here i wouldn't
be surprised that we over here a little
bit more before breaking out okay and if
we break out the next resistance level
would be here guys okay 46 why 46
because it's the high that i have here
it's also a high that i have here so i
have two recent reactions okay we can
maybe put one here okay 40 my height as
okay there is 40 first and then 46
okay
but i believe this the move would be
strong so from here to here at 25 40
might be the first resistance maybe then
slide put back
and then 46
and then once we're here guys it's
looking very good it means that the
bears lost the battle and they're gonna
retreat reach beat retreat and the bulls
are going to keep attacking attacking
attacking and the shots are going to
cover
and then you know the process there is a
lot of gamma sitting
around the 40 strike and there is a lot
of gamma sitting around 145 strike which
is gonna create some very strong bullish
momentum if we start going there so this
might be for me the next move that is
going to play out maybe this week maybe
next week i don't know let's find out
but i think that we are on the right
path so if you guys enjoyed this video
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys